Gus, so here is example for an invalid market structure shift.
So you can see we created this higher, high, high, low, higher, high.
And for me to look for a market structure shift, I want to see this structure broken.
But you can see that when price came near this level, we consolidate it.
Then we came back, touched this line, did not break it, then went back up,
then broke it with only a single candle. Then we had a bullish candle.
So this, there is no momentum in this move, guys.
If there was momentum, I would see something like this, right?
And the fact that the price is consolidating just near this level
gives me a sign that this is not a vetted market structure shift.
And as you can see, we have these candles, we have this consolidation area.
So for me, this is not a valid market structure shift.
And if you took your entry from this auto block right here,
you can see price just pierced through it and it just went back up.
So you, you can notice that there was no volume in this, um,
in this level, right? We had consolidation, we went back to this level.
We did not break it. We just, we just reacted off it.
We couldn't go below this level for two candles on a 15 minute time for him.
So this shows you that there might not be enough volume.
And it could just be, you know, a trap for smart money traders.
And it can, one candle can close below this level, giving you a sign that maybe
this is a market structure shift, but when you take your entry, you are going to
lose. So I hope that is clear.
I'll see you guys in the next video with another topic.